Україна, схоже, йде особливим шляхом у боротьбі з епідемією коронавірусу. У той час, як Німеччина, Франція, Італія, Нідерланди
та низка інших європейських країн запроваджують жорсткі локдауни на різдвяно-новорічні свята,
в Україні суворі обмежувальні заходи почнуть діяти лише після свят - від 8 січня. Чому так?
Шопери штурмують магазини у Берліні. Останній вечір перед суворим локдауном.
Від 16 грудня центральні площі німецьких міст стануть безлюдними.
Роздрібну торгівлю в Німеччині відправляють у вимушену відпустку до 10 січня. Досі тут діяв лише частковий локдаун.
Більше місяця не працювали кінотеатри, театри і музеї, бари й ресторани. Але це не спрацювало - переламати другу хвилю не вдалося.
Після того як упродовж тижня кілька разів фіксували антирекорди померлих від коронавірусу,
влада у терміновому порядку відправила у локдаун ще й роздрібну торгівлю, перукарні, школи та дитсадки.
Ліміт і на приватні зустрічі - максимум 5 дорослих із двох різних помешкань. Незначне пом'якшення чинне лише для різдвяних днів
- додатково можна запросили 4 осіб з найближчого родинного кола, не враховуючи дітей. Анґела Меркель схожа на Грінча, який вкрав Різдво.
Я теж хотіла б, аби м'якші заходи виявилися більш ефективними.
Коли ми зустрічалися тут, то казали, що нам потрібно на 70-75 відсотків зменшити контакти.
А досягли у кращому разі 40 відсотків. І от тепер, через різдвяні події, кількість контактів знову сильно зросла.
Це означає, що ми мусимо вжити цих заходів. Аби не допустити перевантаження нашої системи охорони здоров'я.
Обмеження діятимуть щонайменше до 10 січня. У перший тиждень нового року проаналізують динаміку і вирішать, чи подовжуватимуть локдаун.
Франція зустріне Новий рік комендантською годиною. У листопаді тут була катастрофічна ситуація з коронавірусом - до 90 тисяч нових інфекцій на добу.
Влада тоді запровадила суворі правила. Зокрема залишати помешкання для прогулянок або занять спортом дозволялося максимум на 1 годину на добу
та на відстань не більше 1 кілометра. Завдяки такому жорсткому локдауну французам вдалося досягти зниження кількості нових інфекцій до близько 10 тисяч на день.
Але, незважаючи на поліпшення, французька влада не відмовилася від локдауну, лише трохи послабивши його.
Французам дозволили пересуватися в радіусі 20 км від домівки тривалістю до 3 годин на день.
Перед святами влада ще додатково запровадила комендантську годину від 10 години вечора до 6 години ранку.
Не стане винятком й новорічна ніч - окрім заборони виходити надвір, французам заборонили ще салюти та феєрверки.
Італія теж, на тлі поліпшення "ковідної" статистики, запроваджує суворі обмеження у період святкувань Різдва та Нового року.
Заборонено залишати свій регіон та відвідувати близьких у інших провінціях. Донині правила варіювалися, як і в Україні, залежно від вірусної зони - жовтої, помаранчевої або червоної.
Але напередодні Різдва діятимуть правила "червоної зони" для всієї країни. Зокрема, як і у Франції, з 10 вечора буде комендантська година.
Тому різдвяні меси проходитимуть не увечері, а вдень. Італія має найстаріше населення у Європі, а цього тижня випередила Великобританію за загальною кількістю смертей від Covid.
З огляду на переповнені лікарні, влада не ослаблює карантинний режим.
У Нідерландах 15 грудня запровадили ще суворіший локдаун, ніж у німців, - до 19 січня.
Як пояснив у емоційному телезверненні нідерландський прем'єр Марк Рютте, "іншого вибору не було".
Владу не заспокоїло те, що у Нідерландах останнім часом зафіксували навіть деяке зниження кількості нових інфекцій.
Рішення закрити всі магазини, крім життєво необхідних, неофіційно пояснюють ще й тим, що хотіли уникнути напливу любителів передріздвяного шопінгу із сусідньої Німеччини.
Досі у Нідерландах культурно-розважальна сфера працювала майже без обмежень.
Тим часом українська влада не побачила причин для термінового локдауну. Український підхід - локдаун після свят.
В Україні будуть запроваджені посилені карантинні обмеження. Назвемо їх "зимові канікули заради безпеки".
Це робиться для того, аби не допустити розгортання нової потужної хвилі захворюваності, яка може наступити, зокрема і після новорічних свят.
Аби розірвати ланцюг захворюваності, який може сформуватися протягом свят у тому числі.
Зволікання з локдауном в Україні пояснюють насамперед економічними причинами.
Ми більше трьох тижнів говорили з представниками бізнесу, з місцевою владою, з епідеміологами.
Це робилося для того, аби була консолідована позиція та підтримка рішень уряду України.
Тим часом активісти пацієнтських організацій б'ють на сполох, вказуючи на відсутність вільних ліжкомісць для пацієнтів з коронавірусом в українських лікарнях,
особливо в регіонах, та нестачу кисневих точок для ковідних хворих. Утім, у МОЗ цих проблем не бачать.
Ми бачимо чітко, що ми домоглися саме збиття цієї хвилі коронавірусної хвороби,
цього ураганного розповсюдження. І стабілізували ситуацію. Те, на що ми і розраховували. Результати ми бачимо сьогодні.
Домислами назвав Максим Степанов коментарі про начебто маніпуляцію зі статистикою.
Зниження кількості тестувань міністр пояснив тим, що менше людей з ознаками "ковіду" стали звертатися за тестами.
Щоправда, багато хто нарікає, що влада приховує реальну захворюваність.
І заявляють, що лікарі просто не відправляють на тести хворих, адже встановлені Кабміном правила передбачають безкоштовні тести тільки з невеликим переліком симптомів.
Тепер МОЗ дозволило безкоштовні ПЛР-тести громадянам з будь-якими ознаками респіраторних хвороб, а також їхніх контактних осіб. Досі це було можливо лише за гроші.